well our next guest is Professor Stuart
Russell a British computer scientist
who's known for his contributions to AI
but he's also signed that letter and he
joins us now thank you so much for being
on the program uh with us it's really
fascinating can you just explain why you
decided to sign the letter
um so the letter asks for a pause in the
development and release of systems that
are more powerful than gpt4 which is the
successor of chat gbt that you just
mentioned
um and the reason I signed it I should
say I didn't write it but I signed it
because I think it needs to be said that
we don't understand how these systems
work we don't know what they're capable
of and that means that we can't control
them we can't get them to behave
themselves uh and they're already
causing harm for example uh there was a
gentleman in Belgium who committed
suicide with the advice and guidance of
of a chatbot
um and people are concerned about
disinformation about uh racial uh gender
bias in the outputs of these systems
and we need time to develop the
regulations
uh that will
make sure that the systems are
beneficial to people rather than harmful
um
sorry go ahead so it's extraordinary to
to listen to you um it kind of feels
like the sort of thing that I read about
in science fiction novels you know 10
years ago 20 years ago
um what kind of examples can you give we
sort of showed some of them before like
deep fake songs and images but but what
kind of examples are you most concerned
about
so there's a distinction between the
systems that already exist
um and I think one of the biggest
concerns is disinformation and deep
fakes
um
we've had disinformation for a long time
right I mean propaganda and all that but
the difference here is I can now ask
gbt4 to read
all about Sophie ridges
social media presence everything Sophie
Regis ever said or written uh all about
Sophie Richard's friends
um and then
just begin a campaign gradually by
adjusting
your news feed maybe occasionally
sending some fake news along into your
news feed so that you're a little bit
less supportive of Ukraine
um and you start pushing harder on
politicians who say we should support
Ukraine in the war against Russia and so
on that'll be very easy to do
um and the really scary thing is that we
could do that to a million different
people before lunch
and so you can have a huge impact with
these systems uh for the worse by
manipulating people in ways that they
don't uh even realize is happening
genuinely
be scary if I'm being honest and to
listen to that is that kind of thing
happening now
I would say quite likely yes
um there are we know in China and Russia
uh North Korea large teams of people who
pump out this information uh and we've
just given them a power tool
the concern of the letter is really
about the next generation of a system
um right now the systems I think have
some limitations in their ability to
construct complicated plans uh for
example you know if you wanted
plan for one company to take over
another that's a really complicated
thing and I don't think these systems
can generate those kinds of plans
successfully but quite possible that the
Next Generation or the generation after
could start to do that and then you
could see uh corporations being run by
AI systems uh you could see uh military
campaigns being organized by AI systems
and in the long run the concern is quite
a simple one right if you're Building
Systems that are more powerful than
human beings
how do human beings keep power over
those systems forever
and that's the real concern behind the
open letter
wow really really big questions you're
talking about a pause so regulation can
catch up but you're also saying that
look countries like China and Russia can
use this
so in some ways what's the point of
Regulation when people are just going to
ignore it
so interestingly China just after the
open letter came out issued regulations
that are much stricter than anything
that the European Union is contemplating
or the United States for that matter
um and some people view the Chinese
regulations as a de facto ban on these
kinds of systems we call them the large
language models like chat GPT because
the Chinese rules for example say that
they may not output false information
uh and one of the things we know about
these large language models is that they
lie through their teeth all the time
without even realizing it
um they make stuff up
um
you know and uh
there's no way to control them right we
don't understand how they work inside we
don't understand what makes them uh say
things that aren't true and the only way
we have to control them is basically to
say bad dog
right bad dog and hope that by keeping
on saying bad dog they'll learn to
behave themselves better that's not a
very reassuring method of control for
for systems that can affect the lives of
millions of people
my my concern though is I accept that
you know it's really interesting to hear
about the regulations in China but there
will always be bad actors whether that's
Nations or whether that's individuals so
no matter how much regulation you put in
place can it ever really be safe
I think that's uh that's a really good
point and I've been trying to convince
governments of the need to start
planning ahead for
for the time when we need to actually
change the way our whole
digital ecosystem if you like the way it
works because right now
your computer pretty much runs anything
that people send to it unless it knows
already that it's malware right that it
knows that it's a virus because it has
it has a signature that it can recognize
we actually need to flip that around so
that your computer won't run anything
unless it knows that it's safe
um and if we have it working that way
then we can say okay AI systems that
don't come with a guarantee of safety uh
the system simply won't run them that's
a big change but I think it's something
that's going to be absolutely necessary
in the long run
what does it mean for jobs as well we
were joking about the newsreader well I
mean I was kind of joking about that new
series
um but there are big implications for
people's jobs
yeah so some studies suggest that these
large language models like chat gbt
could affect uh maybe 300 million jobs
in the developed economies
um and I think they're also going to
have a big impact on all the Outsourcing
jobs
that are helping to create a middle
class in in lots of other countries
around the world because Outsourcing
really means breaking jobs down into
small easily digestible pieces
um that people who are not super expert
can tackle and then send back the
results and it's exactly those kinds of
tasks that systems like chat GPT can do
very well they're actually extremely
good at writing uh computer programs for
example so many many programming jobs
could be lost
um and there's a there's a kind of a
mantra going around that you'll hear
from a lot of the tech industry which
says well we're not going to replace
humans we're going to augment humans
we're going to make them more productive
we're going to give them more time to
work on the things that matter
um and I think this is just a mythical
argument because let's say you're a
radiologist right and maybe we can get
AI systems that take care of 80 of the
cases that are just routine
but people are not going to break their
legs in more interesting and complicated
ways just to keep Radiologists in work
right the obvious consequence is that uh
if Radiologists are much more productive
we will need fewer Radiologists
and this is going to happen across the
board
societies need time to adjust
and I'm a little bit worried that
governments are not really thinking
ahead uh about how those adjustments are
going to need to work in our education
system in the structure of our economy
many governments are thinking oh we'll
just retrain people to be data
scientists and robot Engineers but you
know we only need a few million of those
and there's a few billion people whose
livelihoods could be threatened by
systems coming in the future
wow I mean you say you're a little bit
worried I'm more than a little bit
worried after talking to you I will be
honest and it's been fascinating to talk
I could talk to you all morning and I've
also been looking at the time where you
are as well uh half 39 minutes past one
in the morning in California so our
thanks for taking the time out to talk
to us we really appreciate it
very nice talking to you Sophie